Now, let's take a look at a few metahuman sample projects that are available for free
on FAP.
With the release of Metahumans in 2021, the Metahuman sample project was made available.
This project includes a cinematic sequence with high quality body and facial animations.
I have included one of the face and body animations from here, located in the course project assets
folder inside the folder named Animations.
We also have the Metahumans lighting project released in 2022, and this includes lighting
presets made with the help of cinematographer Greg Frazier and three created for the Matrix
Awakens Unreal Engine 5 experience.
I have included the maps from here in the course project assets folder inside the folder
named MH Lighting.
The game animation sample project released in 2024 showcases fully functional animation
systems and includes hundreds of animations and retargetor setups for UEFN skeletons
to Metahumans.
We also have the UEFN Talisman demo, which allows users to explore the Olympic cloth
simulation and optimization of Metahumans for UEFN.
Two other projects worth mentioning are the City Sample Project from the Matrix Awakens
Unreal Engine 5 experience released in 2022 and the ML Deformer sample project, which
showcases Unreal Engine's machine learning technology to create deformations driven by
muscle, flesh, and cloth simulation.
Both of these projects use characters from the Metahuman framework, although they are
somewhat different from the standard ones downloaded from Quixel Bridge.
Now, let's move on to the next section of this course where we begin our journey in
creating Metahumans using the Metahuman Creator.